one of the questions in um
one of the parts rather of question six
which is not one i assigned but question
seven which um maybe you're up to right
now or maybe just gone past um relates
very closely to it so i want to show you
how i've done i'm gonna point out a
couple of things that i alluded to in
the morning class um that i didn't
explain so let's have a look what is the
actual question here it is
they give you um they give you this
binomial expansion and then they ask two
questions they say okay well stand a
question what's the greatest coefficient
but then secondly okay what if i
actually know what x is what if we
designate a particular value like say
two thirds then
i can actually know not just the
greatest coefficient but the greatest
term the whole thing once it's all come
together and simplify it so what is the
greatest term so those are the two parts
of it so let's have a look the first
part of this is pretty standard so i
just want to walk you through it
you can see um i've picked out what my k
and my k plus 1 coefficients are i do my
normal thing and comparing the ratio
between those two and then i crunch my
numbers carefully
to get down to an expression for what
that ratio is so there it is right there
but of course the whole point in finding
what this ratio is is that i want the
ratio to be bigger than one that means
my coefficients keep on increasing so
that's why i've solved this inequality
and this is what i've got
now i got to ask the question before
like
at this point here once you find this
value that satisfies or once you solve
the inequality rather what do you do
from there i think probably this is the
most concise and i think reasonably
watertight way mathematically of moving
from this thing here to then saying okay
i'm going to then evaluate term seven or
coefficient seven um i kind of think
it's a little bit weird if you remove i
know it's a bit awkward to write this
big long thing but it's actually very
useful if you remove that just think
about what the logic is saying you're
like i've got an inequality
i've solved it k must be an integer so
the biggest value that's that is the
solution to that is six and then you go
ahead and go term seven like that's
weird that's a bit strange right so i
think putting it back establishes like
what does it mean the coefficients are
increasing from term six to get to term
seven i had to multiply by some number
bigger than one that was um
that was the premise right
so therefore that makes term seven
bigger than term six and that is what is
reflected here
in this important part of the inequality
okay so
yeah it can get a little bit long um i
will point out if you had say like 50
terms you don't need to write all 50 you
might get up to
the important one and then after some
point you should say dot dot the rest of
it is trivial isn't it you've gotten to
the critical spot the highest the peak
and then
the rest of it's unemployment
so that's how i've worked out the
greatest coefficient you already know
how to do that now let's look at what
happens again this is the question if i
then designate a value for x okay
now you can see what i started with here
was if i'm just interested in the
coefficients then i kind of just take x
out of the equation when i'm working out
what those bits are okay but now that x
is given a value
i can include it in this so i still have
all of these pieces here but have a look
at the way i start part two
can you see what's new you see what's
new let me highlight it for you um right
there and right there there's the value
of x right and it appears
sorry what have i done oh yes of course
sorry this one should say two um
this is the whole term and just like i
had powers of three quarters which is
just part of the coefficient now i have
powers of three quarters x except of
course x is a number so that's why i put
it in there and you can see because the
three's cancel and it's two over four
that's why uh in my lines below you can
see i've got a half a half and those
should also it still says ck because you
can see i actually just copied it so um
those are my comparisons of the actual
terms now
everything else proceeds in exactly the
same way as it did before you still come
up with an expression for what that
general ratio is you still go ahead and
you solve that ratio and then you get to
here right now remember i said to you if
this thing isn't
is actually lands on an integer right
that means you don't just have one
greatest coefficient it means you've got
two now i want you to think about why
that is the case okay
if it's for k is less than seven okay
what happens at k equals seven
k equals seven well i can actually just
go back to my original line up here
and i can just evaluate the thing like
this is telling me what do i have to
multiply to get to the next term have a
look
uh this um this is t
t k plus 1 on t k is going to be equal
to
4 times 9 take away 7 which of course is
2
on
7 plus 1 which is a so this ratio is 1.
it lands right on okay
which means that to go once k equals
seven to get to k equals eight i
multiply by
one which makes those coefficients
identical so that's why now on the next
line you can see
yeah c7 to get to c8 they're the same
thing so this is this is actually really
nice even though it's like oh i have to
write so many terms but this is very
meaningful it shows i understand okay
there's actually not just one
there are two greatest coefficients
there they are i can work out what the
greatest coefficient is in the sorry
that number's actually wrong i think
from memory
i just punched this into my calculator a
second ago i think it's 1152. you can
confirm that if you like but i also can
say you know the term next to it or just
to the right is also going to have the
same value okay
yeah
okay it's not c6 and c7 because the k is
less than seven
right
so so value six it's still increasing
when k gets a seven it's not increasing
anymore but it's not decreasing either
right as i've just demonstrated uh over
over here
right so if k is less than six it's
increasing when k is seven it's not
increasing anymore but it's not getting
smaller so k equals seven is the biggest
one because the next one isn't smaller
it's the same size that's why it doesn't
satisfy this inequality the coefficients
aren't increasing anymore they just
level
okay